takes more accountability men or women
men men men men
why you're shaking your head
say sorry men don't say sorry as much as
women so definitely but men say sorry
and then continue to fix it whereas
women can't say sorry and then continue
to make the same mistake I think women
rarely say something I don't think
across the board I've I've never most
men one of their biggest gripes is that
women they will always move the goal
posts like if they're wrong then they
will kind of CounterPoint on how they
like how you caused it like even if they
cheat well you weren't emotionally
available so it's your fault no matter
what happens there's an excuse I rarely
hear a woman say I'm sorry honey I did
wrong I'm going to work on it you'll
never see me do this again please
forgive me well I think that's exactly
that's exactly accountability
[Laughter]
what were you gonna say not in all
situations but I do think women held
their hands up more than men men slight
that's the thing there's accountability
in gaslighting so
so
um I think that there's a difference
within our society I think that women
have the privilege in our modern day
society today to not be held accountable
I did a story not too long ago about a
year or so ago just popped into my head
where a young lady went down the NBA
All-Star weekend with not enough money
to get back home she then goes on
GoFundMe in order to get money in order
to go back home men cannot do that right
men do not have that type of reach and
or access to get free money sent to them
if they make a boo-boo how so
Society in general just last Quick Point
Society in general has cushions put in
place for women more often than men
that's why most homeless people in
America are men it's like 90 to 10 90
yeah I think when you say that if you if
you go on the modern day tick tocks and
whatever right you'll find videos of
women saying oh how to apologize to your
man just scoot up to him naked with your
ass out right and that shows a lot of
non-accountability that shows when you
say that okay women are more accountable
it's like no that's how they apologize
they think okay if we have sex then
everything's fine and so yeah I think
women don't hold themselves accountable
a lot I think women have a hard time
having that introspection I think if you
do they try to attack people more so
than actually accept that I think in the
time though well we live in a time where
women don't really need to be
accountable in a way that men are always
running around after them which I think
needs to stop and that's why that they
never have to really hold their hands up
and say look I'm sorry what I've done
wrong I'll try to fix this because
before it becomes an actual issue the
man's already there trying to fix what
they've done kind of listening because I
feel like in America this is not the
stance right I feel like the men that I
have come across in the dating spectrum
they are very passive they are not quick
to apologize they are very gaslighting
they don't accept accountability into
your point about a man not being able to
go to Vegas get stuck and not make his
way back you've men these days because
they're in the streets doing whatever
have accumulated a bunch of women that
care for them you can paint her a stop
story and she's going to send you a
hundred dollars because she's caring and
wants to support you right so I think
it's a balance of each depending on the
circumstances in the person but I
definitely think women can be
accountable and from my circle and my
experiences are more accountable in this
generation of men who don't accept
accountability are not they Apologize by
actions right they just show up they
won't accept accountability for what
they did specifically a blanket apology
is not an apology if you are not owning
right that's the definition of lack of
accountability if you oh I'm just sorry
but what are we sorry for what are we
making improvements on right so I have a
question for you what was the last thing
that you apologized for what was the
last thing you took accountability for
um bad communication bad communication
yeah okay what you had something to say
I think maybe sometimes when I lose my
anger sometimes I'll blame it on other
things then the last thing I took
accountability fours when I've gone
there do you know what I ever reacted
with that and I shouldn't have reacted
in that way so I apologize for that
can we clarify that accountability is
not the same as an apology right because
accountability means that there is a
consequence after the action so either
that means okay you did that and because
of that this is the consequence and I
believe that is what men have to deal
with I think a lot of times women think
just by saying I'm sorry I'm accountable
that is not the same thing the amount of
times that I'm in dating relationships
with different women and listen they
just want to just complain about the
problem
I want to fix the problem correct I
don't want to continue to listen to you
just talk about what happened with you
and Marianne in the office right if you
come to me with an issue let's talk
about Solutions all right okay you can't
just waste my time at like that at the
end of the day let's talk about
Solutions but I find as though a lot of
women don't communicate in Solutions so
we talk about accountability the
consequences for that is to solution if
men in general are not accountable they
will not be successful if women in
general are not accountable they can
still be the wife to a CEO and but they
can go on only fans using using that
analogy that same woman will complain to
you about you know um what happened at
work you will say as a man okay cool
what we gonna do about it what are we
doing about how are we going to fix it
how are we going to fix this she would
say oh I just wanted to vent and then
the next week or the next month she'll
be complaining to about the same thing
so it's like okay but
how do you hold yourself accountable do
you want to face this woman or whoever
you have a problem with do you want to
get it out into the air do you want to
help the situation no they just want to
vent so yeah women talk a lot but they
don't
do a lot when somebody commits a crime
do we blame the criminal or do we blame
society
I think good men can become bad where
usually when you see men that have turnt
bad I think they always started out as
good men but being around certain people
in society can change them and twist
them so you guys think it's 50 50. I
wouldn't say 50 50. yes
on a street and I steal something is it
my fault or Society no it's your fault
it's your fault it's nothing to do with
Society like if we want to blame the
system then that's the that's the that's
the Crux of no accountability like like
if you want to just blame what my
childhood my upbringing I didn't have
this I didn't have that the same person
grew up in the same circumstance as you
and they made other choices so we have
to like that's not accountability if
it's if it's always somebody else you
know who who caused it because you were
raised a certain way I can show you the
example of somebody raising a worse
circumstances who made better choices
than you so is it really Society if if
we can if I can point to one person who
made a better choice sorry if I make if
I could poison one person who made a
better choice then
like like you haven't your excuse is
gone but there's a moral and there's a
moral story in that so for instance if
you look at people like Robin Hood right
Robin Hood was born into a poor Society
right and what he chose to do was to rub
from the rich and give to the poor right
so was he was he wrong so I have a
question so if a guy cheats can he blame
society no no absolutely not no he has
no no discipline with his tool
um why can't why can't he just blame
hookup Culture by that logic no just if
you want to hook up yeah be single don't
leave just leave I don't understand that
yeah but why cheats but I think it also
depends on your on your end goal so like
I said with Robin Hood with the Robin
Hood analogy he robbed from the rich
gave to the poor to try and change
society so so women were like they they
this woman
and these poor women out here aren't
getting enough D so he's giving charity
that's essentially what your example is
no I'm just talking about morally
depends on that's why I said it's
depends I never said this 50 50 I said
it could also be the society could also
be the individual I'm just saying I
would say it would depend on what you
want from say so people like if you're
trying to change society for instance
look at Andrew Tate he's trying to
change society right but he's deemed as
wrong that's why he's been jailed just
people don't know right because people
don't like Taylor Swift
If we're honest but he's done things
right I will say there are moves he's
made that people are on on his side will
say listen you you self-snitched like
you you should have kept it quiet
there's moves that he needs to yeah
we're not talking about that we're
talking about whether he's is that
society's fault if you self snitch is he
wrong
and for what he's trying to do with him
if you self snitch you have to learn how
to move we're in the world we're in and
I'm not saying he's right or wrong what
I'm saying is that's what we're talking
about but I'm saying is but he has to
also does Andrew Tate have to take
accountability if he's self-centered but
if you if you you can you can sing about
something in a song or talk about
something on social media without it
technically being self-snitching they
have to bring evidence that you did
those exactly they have no evidence
against him so I agree with you they
have no evidence so they need to let
that go their feelings are hurt so
that's why I said Society because
Society could deem somebody wrong
because they're the ones in the wrong so
if I have power my original question was
about about the Steeler so if I go down
and steal is it my fault or Society but
let's just think if you're if you're
raised in poverty you have no money
you're in a circumstance where you have
no food and you're raising us and you're
living let's say you're a kid and you
have no money you have no food you're
dependent on parents who are on drugs
and and your your baby sister needs to
eat your mother's on crack like there
are nuances in this where you have to
blame a portion of society that this
child has failed because we've let them
slip through the system
but how would that child eat how do they
eat tell me the solutions if their
parents are on crack their baby sister
their little brothers and sisters are
hungry they can't get a job they're 13.
I personally know of people like this
kids and homeless shelters this is their
situation Maggie understood but wrong is
still wrong there may be reasons why
this kid is stealing but we still have
to be able to say wrong is wrong and as
a parent I mean you hear it even in
parenting advice you know they tell you
oh the child is not bad they just made
bad decisions where I grew up in an era
where if you were a fool they called you
a fool yeah and I think we need to bring
some of that back because it breeds this
thing well it's not my fault sometimes
it just has to sit on you and you just
have to realize I did that and it was
wrong so is that a moral question then
like when you say wrong is wrong because
who decides what is wrong and what is
right but then the question is well if
you are let's say you're a teenager or
young your mother's on crack there's a
recent store in the U.S where a mother
left her two children her 14 year old
ran away her 12 year old and she has a
three-year-old all three different baby
daddies she left him alone in Texas and
Houston for two months through
Thanksgiving she told them if you tell
anybody that I'm leaving that they're
going to take your little three-year-old
brother away and you'll never see him
again and threatened her so she was
scared to tell anybody what was going on
her mother was missing for two months or
she was running the streets in another
state she was left in the carrot she
never enrolled these children into
school uh the oldest one so she used to
have to lie to her father who was
working in another state because of
course she got custody of all the kids
okay so then she because she was
threatened because the mother said I'll
never love you or see you you never see
your siblings again this child had to
lie to her father and say can you please
get groceries mom is working he would
call the mother say yeah I'm working can
you please send groceries or food I'm
struggling but she couldn't tell the
truth because she was scared if that
instance if she didn't have food didn't
have the father who would who would send
the groceries or food to the house and
she had to go steal are we going to say
little 12 year old you are now
accountable because your mother's for
the streets and abandoned you in your in
your little sibling and now you need
consequences I think there's you can
have empathy for a situation but the
whole idea is wrong is wrong exactly but
you're saying well with your mom
and you could say this is why I did that
wrong thing and like this is my reason
for it but wrong is still wrong
it doesn't become right just because
something happened exactly exactly it
doesn't matter well it's tough for me
that one that's a tough I think it's odd
so suppose it's the instance if I got up
and slapped you in your face right now
am I wrong yes sir yeah if you snap me
back are you wrong yes no no but
remember you made a decision just let me
no because once in self-defense
if he just slaps you once and then he
just stands there and there's no defense
needed he just slapped you it's still
self-defense
stand up and do it again but but what if
he doesn't what if like he's held back
are you are you should you be able to
see how would he be held how do I get
here
I'm like we've gone in the past I think
you've gone in a path
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible